l'émoi suscité par l'incendié de notre
dame près d'un milliard d'euros de
promesses de dons élan de générosité
exceptionnel
on a tous été évidemment touché est
heureux soulagés de voir que certains
milliardaires qu'on est forte une
gigantesque ont mis à profit de la
rénovation notre dame une petite partie
de leur fortune mais quand même on peut
s'interroger est ce qu'une société qui
dépend du bon vouloir de l'émotion de la
conviction de quelques grandes fortunes
pour orienter c'est donc lui aussi du
coup c ces dépenses fiscales pour
quelque cause c'est une société qui
marche bien est ce que c'est une société
normale d'une société solidaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yves ya trente mille personnes qui sont
mises à la rue par la police
chaque année et on a demandé à cette
occasion à l'état un plan d'urgence de
100 millions d'euros pour éviter cette
hémorragie pour éviter ces drames
quotidiens dans notre pays et on nous
répond à chaque fois il n'y a pas
d'argent mais on a l'impression qu'il ya
pas de volonté politique
alors que quand on est quand on a envie
de faire quelque chose quand on est
touché par une cause comme ça a été le
cas pour notre dame on voit que de
l'argent il y en a à la fois dans la
leur et la réserve de générosité des
français
mais parfois aussi dans les caisses de
l'état donc il faut le mobiliser pour
les causes qui sont importantes
notre dame c'est une cause très
importante c'est une cause à la fois
matérielle c'est aussi une église mais
c'est aussi un symbole
la question du sans abrisme du mal
logement des expulsions locatives doit
être une cause qui doit aussi nous
mobiliser
nous les citoyens et surtout aussi
l'état les collectivités qui doivent
mettre à la hauteur de la générosité
publique des moyens plus importants
aujourd'hui le ministère du logement est
celui qui est le plus impacté par la
rigueur budgétaire depuis deux ans c'est
profondément ce qu'on a lu
m
quand on nous dit qu'on ne peut pas
aller plus loin dans la redistribution
dans les impôts sur les personnes les
plus fortunées
je pense que cet épisode nous montre que
ce n'est pas vrai qu'il n'ya pas une
asphyxie fiscale qui a encore des très
grandes fortunes très très grandes
fortunes qui peuvent faire quelque chose
de leur argent
c'est très bien si ça passe par la
générosité privée on ne peut pas se
contenter de ça il faut aussi que ça
passe par l'action politique et l'action
politique ça passe par une imposition de
ceux qui ont les moyens de payer des
impôts des taxes et manifestement il y
en a encore beaucoup plus l'incendié à
notre dame nous a tous touchés parce que
c'était spectaculaire mais finalement il
ya des causes qu'on ne voit même plus le
fait qu'ils aient plus de 500 personnes
qui meurent à la rue chaque année ça
veut dire deux ou trois par jour
parce qu'en fait c'est plus que 500 il
ya peut-être des milliers qui meurent
chaque année ça ça nous émeut presque
plus parce que finalement c'est devenu
banal c'est on se résigne à ce type de
d'injustice qui sont pourtant criante
qui sont scandaleuses
donc c'est l'occasion pour tous les
français qui ont envie d'être généreux
de se questionner de se dire quelle est
la cause qui moi me tient à coeur
et comment est ce que je peux faire
cette démarche de don ça peut être un
don financier ça peut être aussi un don
en temps en bénévolat c'est aussi très
important c'est aussi important qu'un
don financier
et puis l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
l'abbé pierre il disait la beauté d'une
ville c'est pas simplement une
cathédrale un musée c'est aussi une
ville où il ya pacte audi où il n'ya pas
de mal logés et donc c'est le message
qu'on veut aujourd'hui adressé à à tout
le monde
[Musique]